non so non so se potete dire io c'ero
perché io c'ero bello di ragazzi e ben
vedere questo nuovissimo video sono
parigi oggi siamo su jeep che uno dei
giochi più spacca tastiere che esistano
sul globo
a me è successo di spaccata se lo sapete
se avesse di temelin ovviamente parla
parla pilota non parla vorrei che
parlasse per mandato affanculo però non
parla di questo o meno che ha molta più
voglia di vivere di mere proprio la sua
colonna vertebrale è molto più
funzionante della mia quando sto sul
divano e la sua non è molto funzionata
quando lo vedrete molto presto comunque
quest'uomo a colpi di inguine riesce a a
fare cork delle cose un po va beh questa
roba che sta tenendo comunque tanto sono
andate abbastanza bene perché non vorrei
immaginavo e vi assicuro che è molto
difficile sembra farcela vedersi ma
dovrei mettere la videocamera sulle mie
mani in questo momento che sono tipo
come se giocassi a a twister twister
però con la tastiera è comunque è
l'obiettivo è proprio quello di riuscire
a raggiungere il punto più alto della
mappa prima che l'acqua sopraggiunga io
non sono mai riuscito a finire questo
gioco perché sia tanto gioco si può
finire che non è che va a record valsi
male quando perché nessuno la matiz
momento anche chi l'ha creato però
l'obiettivo in realtà è arrivare in un
determinato punto della mappa è quello è
fatto e vediamo se riusciamo ad
arrivarci alla lazio mi sono già
incastrato qua che non è proprio il
massimo però la vedo importante e
cambiare appiglio e salire con i colpi
di linguine
fratello
perfetto devo arrivare alla figlia
opinato comunque il piccione che avete
visto lì mi rompere le balle anche più
avanti con il problema se io premo il
tasto l ok devi schiacciare e non ho
premuto quello della tua sbagliato da
sociale va bene non ci arrivo devo fare
in fretta prima che arrivi l'acqua
questo è il problema potranno farti con
le braccia un po più lunghe e porco del
demonio amex ok ragazzi buono
non è vero
è invece è vero
non la pillola di madonna dai le
possibile aspetta non e non ci arrivò
mourinho quando ci sono dei punti fatti
apposta per farti bestemmiare tipo
questo dove io non posso prenderla lati
non ci arrivo che non ci può e non ci
arriva non ci arrivavano che non mi
stendo al braccio prima
neanche se lo stendo prima allora la m
la mc arriva va bene allora e ogni volta
che cambio lettera devo fare tipo miz
logo mito non so neanche se lo sai che
se possa succedere quest'anno però miss
logo un dito è che una cosa è molto
stare debito e non andare sulla bel
pezzo di culo di un piccione del cairo
una testata guarda marazzi da quello
perfetto
de vito perché poi se l'hanno fatto
apposta per rompere i [ __ ] un
giovane allora è da ti devi togliere dal
i sei un fastidio pennuto famiglia che
calcio in bocca anche la madonna che
collo fatto colpisce è impossibile
prendere la pila cina di è la birra
preso che w molto buono
la g
allora forse riesco a prendere l'acqua
direttamente se proprio per fare il giro
comunque bravo sono ora che non è facile
e poi è un po dark souls questo gioco un
po dazio con le texture vecchie dai non
è possibile f piccione styla per l'amor
di dio devi stare fermo vietato
nell'altro a spinta sto male sono
arrivato perchè il piccione mi ha
colpito i testicoli bellissimo questa
cosa non era mai successo e oro qui si
sono studiati più avanti proprio le
lettere distanti no dall'altra
perché lati fastidio morgana guarda
oddio l'ha preso la preso due ore e
mezza incredibile aspetto
f guido togliere questo è bene spect 0
ma gli schiaffi che ti pigli avanti così
guarda ora se è meglio così va al 6
sicuro
no fermi e adesso che cazzo faccio
control f perché ho schiacciato contro
leffe homer me l'ha tenuto me l'ha
tenuto anche ridotto a icona che culo
ragazzi che giocata incredibile ridotta
icona joe cole ottenuto non so come
madonna
dall'italiano man mano che vai avanti si
mette proprio dove dà fastidio quello il
problema l'agi aveva questa parte
possibile raga quanto lisanti cosi ok
l'ho preso non so come ma va bene così
va bene così casta katsav edizione tu
dovresti andare dove non sta la gente
non dove sta la gente a rompere i
[ __ ]
madonna va in piazza del duomo calze
stai qua io veramente non ho parole in
questa vita inc madonna che calcio gli
ho dato è volato nella troposfera ok la
parete blur non hai capito ma che è la g
ma questo perche muscoli che cosa cazzo
mangia la mattina ragazzi aiutatemi a
questo qua c'è nei muscoli che è
veramente fuori di testa hai fatte le
olimpiadi lo zio questa è buona e ragga
questa è buona l'e.coli però credo che
volevo andare io ma gunnes oddio fatto
un giro strano però sai che mi è
piaciuto e poi dove cazzo mia figlia no
la via del social saranno mica non me la
ricordavo sta roba e come cazzo faccio
scusa
nome non può
nora che è impossibile
è impossibile
scusatemi nov avendo non posso fare
questa cosa
ed io l'ho fatto l'ho fatto
minchia raga io non so come ho fatto io
non so come ho fatto non lo so non so
come ho fatto mi sono salvato il culo in
una maniera impossibile
ok
no ragazzi del bureau non so come
cacchio fatta falsa roba ho fatto un
salto
non so come ho fatto ha fatto salto
pazzesco è ma io sono attaccato qua con
la mano sbagliata però
mannaggia devo devo attaccarmi prima con
l'app con la destra no non so ma riesco
a fare sta roba e ragazza aspetta ci
prova
come faccio attaccabili con la destra
impossibile ma devo fare così e poi
andare sul lavoro perché poi vi serve la
sinistra per fare sta roba
ok a per fare così ce la farò allora
devo fare un mezzo saltino è
no madonna ci hanno dato quasi
mai lo salta ragazza
o bellissimo bellissimo che giocatore
che è il giocatore dai addio sto male
lo zio 20 minuti bellissimo press tour è
stato bellissimo quest uomo forzuto e
muscoloso non sono io però io ho avuto
tenacia oggi tenacia incredibile lo
stato bravissimo
non avevo mai finito gf mi sa
no al sicuro nuovo mai finito lì non a
ricordo sta roba bellissimo che è
giocata cacchio ci sono voluti dieci
anni più o meno beh ragazzi questa è la
jeep verona botta non facevo meno male
ci ho messo un sacco a finirlo perché
l'ho fatto un sacco di tempo fa spero
che vi sia piaciuto sono contentissimo
dei risultati che ho ottenuto nella mia
vita come sento ragazzi seguito piace al
momento mi piace anche al sociale che
come io totale estinzione sono state sin
schiette mm con semplici via ad un
prossimo video ragazzi
[Musica]